c'est christophe gérard baro quatrième
étage musique voilà ce soir ça commence
avec christophe y at il un héros sous
les toffes il ya sûrement à égayer un
peu fêlé dont les standards sont dans
l'histoire interview signée luc d'un mec
qui gagne à être connu et stuff bonsoir
alors tu sors un double album 23 titres
qui s'appelle succès fou avec l'éthique
du début c'est-à-dire aline les
marionnettes avec l'époque des albums
les mots bleus señorita tout est bien ce
dans le disque à part la pochette est
fasciste c'est risqué ouais bon problème
on ne prend pas un discours des pics et
picasso c'est un truc qui fait aussi un
peu
c'est parce qu'annulant le disque enfin
tant que c'est que ça tu t'en fous toi
et non je comprends je suis pas d'accord
mais bon on s'est fait ouais antennes et
à juvisy-sur-orge ton père était
installateur de chauffage central ouais
et elle est étalée sur la côte console
wii
[Musique]
jma grande époque de la côte d'azur
entre 9,64 ouais c'est avec une chanson
des commandes et qui s'appelait à
washington ouais tu le faisais ça que je
faisais c'était pas connu jetait dans
les boîtes de nuit d'abord et après je
t'ai dans l'est dans les pizzas est-ce
que c'était pas connu j'ai écouté ces
gens là ouais c'est un traditionnel
j'écoute ces gens là sur fun radio
carolin un essai sortie en france allant
au près et moi quand je chante et ça je
disais que c'était moi qui la composent
est toujours bon c'est super machel page
avec 15 ans alors en 1964 tu vas gens
les peintures rencontre une fille qui
s'appelle aline natta nowitzki était
assistante d'un stomato et qui vais
toujours tu écoutais justement chanté
the rising sun il est d'après pour l hta
qu'on creuse et aligne 65 tube énorme
il ya eu un procès quand même avec jacky
molard parce que ça ressemble à une
chanson qui réussit sortie en 62 capes
et la romance mais ça ressemblait
vraiment ça semblait pas mal disséminer
un effectivement bon et un procès je les
perds du blocage du 45 kg cartes saisies
des recettes est tout même sa part
rigolé du tout la web émission je
reprends j'avais 20 ans je dis rien
c'est juste ce qu'il fallait partie des
sommes qu'il va leur roulotte dire moi
c'est un sac à langer ma vie alors 66
staff et les marionnettes 67 monsieur le
professeur en fait avait la haine des
tubes qu'on ne sait pas du tout ce que
tu voulais faire toi tu voulais faire du
rock qui vous l'êtes dernier baby à
l'ailé ou ligue en quoi ouais mais c'est
moi je vais plus faire du blues
parce que veut ce qui m'a bercé dans les
années 60
quand même au coeur la king slim harpo
tous ces gens dario est ce que c'est pas
le fait d'être devenu un tube heures
français par rapport aux blues que tu
voulais chanter qu'il a donné une espèce
de n2 toi et qui t'a amené à faire
toutes ces conneries parce qu'on a fait
après des conneries là à partir de 67
non je crois que j'ai vu la haine de
bois non c'est l'image que j'ai donné
c'est pas de ma faute les gens qui en
fait on fait une baisse de presque en
garde est nu c'est vrai que bon un gala
par jour le pognon qui arrivait comme
pas possible tu t'achètes un flat avec
terrasse dans le xvième les bolides
enfin tu es parti dans un drôle de trip
un peu un peu pop star c'est voeckler
plus la défense et l'alcool quand même
regarder koné parti comment la défoncer
sa trace à sarajevo ash ouais donc
effectivement je vous met pas beaucoup
ce qui est un peu par la suite nous
empêcher de commandos de décrire et
quant au bout d'un an et demi deux ans
je finis un assez grave l'ajac mois
n'arrive pas à trouver une idée j'aime
aller mais parce qu'on 69 tu t'es
retrouvé ruiné disparu à un moment tu as
eu le trou noir oui 68 60 60 une tête
j'étais bien j'étais loin de tous âges
étaient dans un rêve j'étais revenu dans
- est intervenu en 73 c'était
gymnastique je me faire pardonner je
fais la peinture je suis sage et là ça
fait tous ses albums avec jean michel
jarre est sympa mais bon c'est une
époque formidable
depuis longtemps donc ce trou noir c'est
a desservi finalement ces sites avaient
servi à 2 ouais mais tous les trois ans
à venir si j'étais riche qu'aujourd'hui
tous les tournois et c'est le trou noir
comment que je crois qu'à aller mais
parce que j'ai besoin de ça moi je peux
pas toujours
il faut que je m'arrête commence à être
aimé par la critique à ce moment là et
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui des gens
comme comme bâillon par exemple 10 ya un
côté yéyé pourri chez christophe un peu
mencé bonne image quand même un peu
gérard manset
il a du goût vaio attention je pense que
comme nom moi je pense qu on est quand
même dans un écart du tout ça je pense
mais le côté yéyé pourri c'est vrai un
peu quand même dans ses albums
ouais le sournois un peu bizarre mais
bon c'est tout le problème de ces albums
quand j'analyse aujourd'hui par rapport
à l'album est en train de faire toi
c'est un peu le texte est ce que tu en
entends bon je fais un truc comme merci
de jeunes devenus au mariage et la
chance je suis fier parce que c'est toi
tu l'as mis dans la vieille ville ben
ouais bien sûr bah oui c'est parce que
c'est tout ce que j'aime j'ai écrit un
truc je me surprends moi même ma famille
seigneur est allé manger comment moi je
suis année créneau moi ça peut être par
être construit le dire on va peut-être
me prendre pour l'argent le jeudi même
si elle est un terreau qui m'écoutent
moi je peux écrire des trucs méfiant tu
as dit je fais que je fais que des 45
parce que c'est les seuls qui rentre
dans les boxes ouais c'est ça qui fait
de 45 marché 45 tout ça on va jouer très
sûrement si tu reconnais 10 des autres
est ce que tu es prêt pour le blind
pêche
ils attestent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean-pierre sur la chanson ces mondiaux
classé chanté nwèl chanter avec lui font
face à levon chanter dans mon grenier
pendant des années à mon piano ouais
t'es tout petits la web si j'ai toujours
l'habitude de chanter ça sur un disque
un jour pierre c'était c'était mon idole
avant le blues avant de connaître s'il
veut le rock and roll et le blues la
musique tu veux c'était ça et bratz a
introduit way départ piaf et grâce à ça
tu jouais chez toi ah ouais mon grenier
social s'agit visite à djibouti
ces indices de tes parents
pas du tout c'est moi qui ai acheté
maman trop près mes parents qu'est ce
qu'ils foutent est excusé mais jean
rameau mestrallet ce n'est plus sûr
contractuellement shepley
mon père n'a jamais été vraiment les
jeunes étaient très branché dans la
musique
ma mère beaucoup plus ma mère chantait
ma mère chantait comme piaf c'est de là
que tu tiens ces merveilles ma mère
quand elle chante à merveille comme le
chantait la main
mais entièrement contrôlé
on n'applaudit pas alors que de plus en
plus
et gagner des titres j'avais un truc
sous sur leur terrain et écouter
beaucoup parce qu'au travers de métis
écouter tes potes c'est vraiment un
moment j'ai hésité
mon choix était traduit en traduit ses
copains ouais j'avoue franchement ces
deux génies de génie lui bon et il a
fini plus tôt
et quand tu faisais dany baby c'est ça
que tu chantais à welch était en fait
jean vincent le crâne sur terre comme on
a dit ça mais j'étais jeune j'aimais
côté un peu imitateurs c'est ce qui me
gênait c'est ce qui m'a gêné le côté
jean le chanteur français qui en tombant
dans sa série gars je sais pas prêts à
faire tout tout tout les chanteurs
français qui retomberait sur certains
gars coûts élevés dit un truc drôle tu
as dit le rock and roll a disparu en 59
avec l'aileron de l'acadie ouais c'est
vrai parce que je pense vite
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup grâce à ce
matériau est déjà commencée n'y avait
aucun média mais cette période j'ai
quitté une piste déjà moi je quittais la
trahison historique hôtel tous les
commandes
la houle est aussi un an
m
[Musique]
s'explique en large pourquoi chercher
des québécois tout est expliqué le
risque est grand mandarin m'explique on
perd on passe au suivant
ah bah ça c'est au coeur oui mais non
non non non non
au début j'ai cru tout en france qu'en
fait c'est mon pti mais je te dire que
c'est pourquoi c'est mon pti salle des
fêtes sais pas pourquoi c'est pas ce
qu'on leur propose
pourquoi j'écoute c'était au coeur parce
que monty qui est un mec qui avaient du
talent est vrai avait pas qu'ils étaient
bien j'en avais mon bien vrai et c'est
un truc vraiment à la hauteur et les
trucs de au coeur qu'il avait pompé
légèrement enfin bon ça c'est pas de
chance pt c'était chez chris bake ta
guitare c'est qui paye bout alors un peu
à evry baptisera king ces caisses qui
devenu un mec comme monty bien conduite
et je tenais à te demander il est venu
chez moi ya un mois non je peux t'aider
nouvelle adresse
que sont ils devenus la c1 il s'est
marié avec une américaine et je crois
qu'il ya grandi avec elle elle est
souvent l'amérique et je crois qu'il est
branché en fait dans les trucs
quand je lui ai dit que je voulais faire
un clip là il m'a dit écoute je peux
peut-être te faire la synthèse avec
martin scorsese que j'adore avant j'ai
dit bon ça colle entre nous mais c'est
bon ils ont le plus je me sentais qu'il
va plus
voici ce que nous disions mettrons alors
tout je pas trompé laissez moi tant que
je vais pas trouver le nom parce que mes
chers de la mémoire mais les vraiment
juke est toutefois j'en parle encore
véronique haut niveau qu'est ce que moi
je vais t'aider ce que tu sais ce qui
est devenu non la new york
ouais il est à new york savoir travail
dans la télé ouais
deux secondes mais bien sûr tout le
monde dit elle
[Musique]
je veux faire vite alors que tu mens pas
ce qu'il en aurait dit qu'est ce que ça
va
ah non je suis vraiment là tu vas mourir
quand je vais dire mais chez qui c'est
mais cbc me passer de ma part des médias
je sais qui c'est bon tu sais que c'est
la limite je préfère même pas que tu me
dises toi bon gtv6 pas voilà je tenais à
l'est ont continué par km en mode
jukebox en rentrant soit là c'est à dire
[Musique]
ça c'est la salle à
quelqu'un que j'aime bien ça
cetrel aurélien ça a été pas loin là
quand même
bah oui mais si vous
may say you read mais c'est quoi le
groupe le groupe là bas ça c'est le
velvet
bravo bush est pour toi c'est la musique
ce bon mois mais ouais quoi te plaît sa
séquence avait ni commencé à écouter ça
que tu as fait après le côté un peu y
est pour rien
ouais hein je l'avais en moi j'avais
devant moi c'est si j'ai pas pourquoi ça
a rendu le truc après quoi c'est ce qui
m'a donné envie est passé d celle ci est
et ouest et parolier là pour l'instant
j'ai pas beaucoup ça n'avance pas ouais
je pense pas j'ai fait donc il ya un
album de 10 chansons peu près
j'ai écrit un texte et c'est un peu mon
problème musicalement c'est fait alain
il est prévu pour toi ben écoute alain
that i m'en parler un petit problème en
ce qui concerne alain sait que
d'acquitter son appart ya un mois et
demi maintenant et il n'a plus jamais eu
de nouvelles
à moins justement tu veux en parler
c'est tombe bien parce que j'aimerais
que si nous aussi nous écouter nous qui
nous appellent parce que bon on les aime
beaucoup et on a le coeur serré par une
souffrance et du souci alors bon on fera
qui nous appelleront ça sera bien
d'accord ce serait bien ou non mais si
les gens qui t'a entendu
voilà qui le voit il faut qu'il nous a
pas d'accord au suivant armés
un dégât alors ouais c'est ça c'est très
fort
assez dommage poursuite n'a pas trouvé
bien tu trouves ça c'est vachement dur
celui ci devient j'étais dire c'est
dommage mais je suis j'ai pas trouvé je
connais par coeur
mon métier vous le dire à la fin dit non
on tulle m alan tieger a déjà fait
partie mais ouais ouais comme bowie
ouais ouais c'est vraiment quelqu'un
dont il adore ouais ouais ouais au coeur
ouais
[Applaudissements]
santana qui broie like jagger
mais ce qui compte avant tout un plaisir
la c29 trois notes quoi ah bah ouais
ouais non c'est bien mais c'est bon
j'achète j'ai bon j'avais tout mon coeur
tu vois dans les années 58 60 et au
genre 90 voilà l'album qui file un flash
c'est au coeur doit s'acheter au coeur
moi c'était pas savoir ce que ça m'a
fait quand je suis allée acheter au
coeur va nous amener j'adore mes jeunes
alors qu'il nous fait d'un flashback
c'est génial alors maintenant dix mois
le mec dont on n'a pas trouvé le nom là
comme ça tu feras sans faute et on le
laisse se concentrait calmer le blouson
de cuir ou les cheveux comme ça le seul
cas comment les douilles comme l'avion
sur l'eau avec les nerfs pour ni beurre
oliver
ségolène et moi bravo cinq ans d'absence
il a choisi les champs elysées pour
faire son retour à la télévision voici
christophe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
christophe là je vous dis à vous avez
fait le plus dur une fois que vous êtes
assis là dessus après ça le plus dur
c'est de mon père est plus haut ouais
comment ça va ça paris rabat comme
quelqu'un qui se lève enfin qui s'est
couché tard et qui le message clair là
ce matin 8h 9,1 à non non j'ai fait
plutôt ce genre 7,82 soit 20,4 rennais
en effet j'ai fait des découpages que 90
du découpage
oui c'est pour ça que j'ai c'est parce
que le découpage ces découpages de cette
nuit elle dit quoi la maîtresse a
dépensé
[Applaudissements]
on est content
elle est d'accord pour que je fasse
partie le mercredi après-midi de la
garderie avec des enfants nouvelle ça
donc pour moi c'est merveilleux parce
que c'est vrai que ça monde est terrible
merci christophe en tous les cas d'avoir
choisi tout le monde en parle pour votre
retour à la télévision c'était 50 qu'on
vous a pas vu et vous revenez avec un
album qui vient de loin il vient d'où
cet album il vient de d'une sensation de
déséquilibre qui fait que j'écris des
notes depuis cinq ans de belgique j'ai
terminé l'autre album était aussi un
petit peu en suspension et donc dans ma
suspension quotidienne maison d'où le
titre comme si la terre penchait qui est
pas mal du tout entre candidats les
arpents choix c'est pas du tout métal et
ce très jeune c'est pas mais tu as du
tout ni où ni un symbole mais ça peut
être aussi interprété comme ça et donc
c'est toutes les petites notes que je
prends c'est pour ça que je suis avec
mais avec vous continuez à travailler
tout le temps vous pouvez sans arrêt
dénotant oui je dire papa ce qui se
passe j'aime bien
vous savez comment on fait
à
voilà donc ça s'appelle comme si la
terre penchait on va y revenir à cet
album d'abord on va se demander d'où
venez vous christophe
christophe c'est bon yann on voit la
culotte de la fille de tool
[Applaudissements]
moi je viens gravats
c'est un travail et amis si sa joie
non ça commence déjà avec un lien à la
copine de corti déjà on sait plus quoi
faire et la cde suis un minimum de
sérieux
excusez-moi j'ai interrompu votre vrai
nom christophe c'est daniel bevilacqua
et voilà et vous vous êtes appelé
christophe en fait c'est quand vous
étiez adolescent vous adoriez les
bagnoles et votre grand mère vous avez
offert un très beau saint christophe qui
est le patron des conducteurs saint
christophe
oui je suis fait voler et dans une
voiture était vous l'avez pu non plus ne
vous a gardé les a gardées le prénom
donc de christophe vous êtes né en
octobre 45 à juvisy sur orge
vous êtes fils d'un petit entrepreneur
d'origine italienne de domodossola
et comme j'étais petit xavier souvent en
vacances en italie avec vos parents
beaucoup à milan parce que il y avait
une partie de la famille milan puis une
partie à domodossola quoi dans la vie de
famille chez vous quand vous étiez petit
c'était pas très drôle parce que vos
parents sont violés tout le temps mais
ils se parlaient pas ouais donc il ya
une séparation et puis voyez puis voilà
et puis je me suis puisse retrouver
retrouver enfin retrouvé c'est beaucoup
dire mais ailleurs que 1 mais aussi
beaucoup avec ma mère avec qui j'ai
j'adorais être puisqu'elle était
couturière et que j'adorais nager dans
les chiffons et dans les faits les
épingles c'est pour ça que j'étais là en
pension parce que c'était insupportable
vie à la maison chez leurs pensions
parce que
[Musique]
parce que je me suis dit ça y est c'est
faire du roman jeu une fois j'avais de
relance plutôt à faire semblant de
rentrée le lundi partir ailleurs
si vous accompagner au lycée vous avez
fait dix lits c'est quand même le
dimanche et vous accompagner au lycée
puis dès qu'ils avaient de tournai ou
fugué c'est ça oui je sais faire gauler
hippiques et un jour quoi à ma mère
inquiète préoccupation principale à
l'époque s'était dessiné des bagnoles et
des grands à sandro non je ne faisais
que ça en cours ouais surtout pendant le
prendre là la 5e 4e 3e là où je vis là
je me suis arrêté où j'étais au fond de
la classe en fait mais pas pour c'était
juste pour écouter le prof de philo le
première parce que il y avait en fait
lui qui m'avait qui m'intéressait ce qui
peut paraître étonnant pour l'en pour un
primitif brut alors ce pan de la musique
vos premières passions c'est brassens
et puis dans votre grenier sur le piano
vous champ que j'écoute chessa
[Musique]
les
allez c'est loin
[Musique]
nous a marqué ça c'est ce qui m'a donné
envie de jouer sur ce piano qui était
complètement faut effectivement en du
grenier où on avait créé une boîte pour
les surboums du jeu dix minutes du jeudi
puisque à l'époque c'était le jeudi la
fête et le samedi comme dimanche et le
lundi et le mardi qu'après le mercredi
et la semaine d'après si vous assumez
donc ans après en fait la vraie
révélation musicale pour vous christophe
ça a été le blues avec robert johnson
john lee hooker et un matin ouais un
matin vous tirez vos pompes parce que
vous seriez vachement vos pompes à
l'époque vous cracher dessus maintenant
à tout le temps tout le dirait une pub
pas mouillé c'est pas une pompe ciré
couet et à la radio vous entendez ça
[Musique]
on ne sait pas
vous dites quand tu écoutes ça pour la
première fois avec la trézence à te fais
un truc
ouais c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est bon je ne peux pas expliquer quoi
que à chaque fois que je suis même
aujourd'hui sur sa temporal d'écouter le
njawe new skies le grand plaisir que
j'ai eu puisque j'ai tellement aimé
effectivement en pension à montlhéry
quand j'étais la nation et puis c'est
vrai mes pompes du matin parce que parce
que sinon on l'avait effectivement les
cool hein le premier jour j'ai entendu
ça c'était incroyable c'était un son
particulier cette pâle blues pas le rock
c'était un mec un génie un g1 génique et
un jour à la fin des années 50 c'est ça
que vous entendez
[Musique]
où
c'est trop beau dire c'est qu'en
cochrane qui m'a qui m'a et puis ensuite
qui a donné aux trucks vous dites leur
canon la disparue en 59 avec l'aileron
de la cadillac de sa 39e dorado ouais
falardeau me fallait des moyens principe
parce qu'il ya une énorme différence
entre une convertible toute simple et
une soixante deux je veux dire et puis
et puis une eldorado et puis là brougham
aussi alors c'est à cette époque
christophe que vous commencez à a pensé
à quitter juvisy sur orge pour la côte
d'azur vous commencez à fuguer
vous avez sur la côte d'azur en stop
ouais avec surtout d'une quête une
guitare à l'arrivée un truc génial
christophe c qui faisait la manche en
jouant dans les boîtes dans les pizzas
dawn of the rising sun vous l'aviez
entendu sur radio caroline
il disait aux gens c'est moi qui l'ait
écrit finalement personne d'autre le
connaissez j'écoutais radio carolin
effectivement depuis un an 20 et ses
marqueurs et gibbons puis il ajoutait je
la chantais bien parce que j'ai parce
que je l'aimais des virements chantait
sous l'ailé mais puisque je chantais du
blues surtout je vais maintenant je
faisais la manche en chantant l'hymne
c'est moi qui écris c'est super ccc
mentir c'est celle imaginaire quand
c'est super de documenteur vous faut
semer filtrer menteur un peu moins
terrain nantais on va voir tout à
l'heure alors en 61 vous faites votre
premier groupe dehli baby et les
hooligans ce vous jouez le samedi dans
des clubs à jouy en josas et puis après
le vol drouot eddie barclay et vous
sortez un quatre titres et une chanson
qui s'appelle reviens sopheak programmée
par daniel filipacchi pour vous le fait
d'être programmé dans celle des copains
par dell filipacchi c'était mieux mieux
que devant des dix finalement à wassit
je suis pas tim programme est donc une
fois way puisque j'étais face à france
gall qui joue à des poupées de cire
ouais et donc il fallait que les gens
choisissent c'est vrai que le choix
était assez facile
ouais mais ce qui était important
effectivement c'était le son de la voix
de daniel filipacchi à lens en revient
se fit à nouveau qui comme on sait comme
passer chez pivot pour un écrivain quoi
la consécration
je suis passé une fois ouais alors bon
ça marche pas très bien revient sophie
vous faites vous retourner faire des
études jusqu'au bepc et là en 65 yassa
jeu
dessiner
sur le sable
son
visage
[Musique]
qui ne sourit
puis il a plu
[Musique]
sur cette double jeu
cet orage
la spa
[Musique]
quarante ans après ça marche toujours
c'est incroyable vraiment largués quand
même un premier titre revient à sophie
way
après j'ai crié aline pour qu'elle
revienne mais il ya eu de la gueule
c'était le premier devrait ce lot de
l'été à un million d'exemplaires
et puis voilà toujours vous serez
maintenant de toute façon l'auteur
d'aline alors c'est aline elle
s'appelait aline la tanovic 23 ans
allez la dame avait 23 ans assistante
d'un stomatologue vous l'avez revue
aline non non non non j'ai un bon
souvenir c'est effectivement cette
chanson qui commet qui pour moi reste la
plus belle
un bien joli un mec qui lui demande qui
vous quelle est la plus belle chanson du
monde et retour à ligne par christophe
bien sûr mais contrairement au jeune
chanteur qui rogne et les chansons de
l'an passé le voyez tout à fait et le
mec était un peu choqués vélib attendait
oui c'est ça pour moi c'est le ménage
chanson du monde ben ouais ouais tu es
caveau de famille à cette époque là ils
sont très contents c'est un meilleur
cadeau que le bepc faut bien le dire
et puis mais faisait quand même des
problèmes d'adaptation dans le show
business à vous avez du mal à étudier
parce que vous avez le cheveu coup un
tee-shirt noir vous êtes à l'écart des
autres
vous prenez pas pour une vedette n'ai
pas d'agent faisait pas de secrétaire
effectivement j'aime pas trop avoir
quelqu'un de toujours avec moi toujours
avec moi je suis j'aime bien pouvoir
être en suspension sur mon nuage d'or
dit non et puis voilà quoi
[Musique]
je vais
puis 7
dumas pied
elle
je vis
[Musique]
gvt est
je vais
et voilà après service militaire dans
les paras bataillon disciplinaire et ça
vous a pas disciplinés du tout
d'ailleurs vous désertez vous retrouve
au val de grâce
hélas lors vous resté deux mois allongé
sur le lit en train de faire tomber des
cendres de cigarettes sur votre poitrine
comme ça quand on vous pose la question
vous dites c'est la seule sensation que
je puisse avoir
c'était effectivement une forme de 2,2
médias mais d'être dans lévitation un
peu par rapport à la à l'imaginaire qui
travaille tout le temps et cette réalité
qui était là il est pas mal vont se
faire réformer sur abc fait réformer
avec landry pour un dingue laisser faire
est formel il a tout fait pour ça mais
ça tu vois un mec dans la ligue qui se
crame le torse avec les clubs quand même
qu'il dit alors lâché mais c'est ce
qu'ils sont et l'enlacé alors c'est
quand même une époque où sans devenir
une une star yéyé malgré tout vous
conduisez vite vous casser des bagnoles
un jour vous avez une lamborghini pas
casser la lamborghini quand même sur les
champs-elysées ouvriers deux feux rouges
vous rentrez dans une voiture de flics
devant le lido oui
[Applaudissements]
mais bon je suis né mais surtout peu
polnareff à côté de moi qui qui lui est
venue beaucoup de moi j'ai comment je me
cachais gérants car je dois y aller il
m'a laissé un mot mais ce cas survient
pas même pas de permis pendant pendant
cinq ans 1 oui et là maintenant vous
l'avez le permis aujourd'hui la course
moment nous non plus non moi je chante
elysée a repris les chances que j'ai
fait un peu trop d'excès de vie de mon
d'excès de vitesse et puis j'ai plus de
points et puis je dois repasser le code
voilà mais bon si on peut vous aider que
les soeurs c'est surtout pour s'échapper
xxx assez content mais bon après ça donc
après aline après les marionnettes
quelques morceaux vous disparaissez des
hit parades et des bacs à 10 vous
quitter la scène yéyé vous quittez votre
appartement dans le 6e arrondissement
vous allez habiter à juvisy dans un
petit pavillon à côté de celui de vos
parents entre juste en face de l'école
des filles parce que les affaires de
pédophilie
on a dit qu'on n'en parlait pas de la
boulette donc non la vous vendez des
bagnoles américaine et vous partez
insensé cette histoire avec le cirque
gruss vous fait cinq chansons par jour
pour 500 francs avec le cirque gruss
vous jouer aux boules avec zanatta vous
commencez à mener une vie comme c'est un
peu comme stéphanie de monaco maintenant
d'ailleurs elle avec le cirque gruss
parlant et non en est avec le cirque
knie est donc à trois mois pendant trois
mois trois mois vous rentrez dans la
cage aux lions avec arlette gruss les
garder et même pas de photo d'ailleurs
alors quand vous partez du cirque gruss
on vous fait cadeau d'un petit lyon 1 0
et que vous baptisé christoph hein vous
le gardez avec vous comme ça pendant
dans les chambres d'hôtel culioli matin
cry 2 s est d'apporter le petit déjeuner
c'était l'enfer et puis un jour vous le
donner à un mac à nice qui s'occupe des
lattes de l'étang qui qui qui est avec
qui avait des animaux voilà ce qui m'a
dit écoute on se rend compte comme ça et
il commence à devenir un petit peu le
lion que j'étais attaché à la rochelle
la partie de boules et commençait à une
chercheure il me connaissait il était
très attaché et donc c'est cheap modibo
il sera bien à nice effectivement dans
mon dans mon espace et puis c'est comme
ça que j'ai réfléchi et j'ai dit oui je
parle en et un jour christophe ouvre le
journal le wii wheel ouvre le journal
et il voit marquer le lion christophe et
moore oui
ah oui il ya une chanson là dessus
c'est vrai nom c'est vrai le lion
christophe est mort
oui c'est vrai c'est de faire un
choletais vous passez quelques années
comme ça on ne sait pas trop ce que vous
faites et en 73
vous rentrez chez les disques motors de
francis et hélène dreyfus et là jean
michel jarre vous fait quelques jolis
textes parce que tout le monde croit
qu'il a fait les musiques en fête
il a fait les textes j'en ai fait déjà
les musiques c'est christophe et ça
donne ça
bon
il avait les
le sang
puis il
[Musique]
il est
je
ces mythes
il
[Musique]
soixante dix huit parole de bob decout
ma préférée
isidore
[Musique]
nury beau jeu
bon j'arrête parce que on pourrait
l'écouter toute la nuit christophe
parole de bob decout un peu menteur élan
vous color me changer d'image là c'est à
dire que l'ex yéyé devient dandy vous
avez un public d'un seul coup beaucoup
plus intello et vous dites c'est vrai
qu'à ce moment là j'ai pris une façon
particulière de chanter parce que je
commençais à déchanter des chinois cic
s'est essayé de commande d'aller dans
afin d'aller comme ça spontanément dans
un air un peu dans l'accident qui fait
qu'il ya mais toujours dans un la terre
qui penche pas toujours un peu dans la
déséquilibre dans la rondeur line waimes
esthétique tous d'accord dans la nuit
qui donne vraiment une différence et qui
fait qu'il n'ya d'une émotion
particulière qui s'entend pas c'est ce
que j'aime tendance tend ce que j'ai ce
que j'écoutais ce que j'ai fait
et puis avait ça dans le même album
[Musique]
le co avait ceux dédiés
mais lorsque son tour un ami qu'on peut
passer
je vis de ma vie christophe le mot
bizarre et puis alors après bizarrement
vous revenez après tous ces concepts
album vous revenez à des à des 45 tours
qui ont beaucoup de succès comme ça
[Musique]
ça
et ça
[Musique]
vous dites je n'ai jamais considéré ce
qui m'arrivait en termes de carrière
j'ai toujours suivi mon instinct c'est
vrai oui une émotion l'instinct quand on
voit votre carrière là c'est très
chaotique en fait j'ai dit ça va dans un
style sera donc à nouveau beaucoup
d'attrait parce que un côté mais ce que
j'aime analyse banalise très peu quoi
mais je préfère vivre que je suis pas un
carriériste quoi c'est pas bon du tout
quoi tout un artiste s'il s'est passé
jusqu'à le way
peut-être je suis parti je suis moi quoi
je suis sur ma route
[Musique]
vous savez quand ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle on vous l'a dit on à bouchain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà l'autre se croire ça mais qu'est
ce qui se passe mais je vais dans le
public pourra commencer à fait j'ai
chirac dans le public quand tu
t'approches de sept cas pas de culotte
sur tout non non non elle est élue vous
pensez à quoi là j'ai toujours tendance
à penser un petit peu à la seconde qui
bien que c'est le plus beau moment de la
miss et c'est la seconde qui le
déséquilibre est toujours vers la
seconde suivante oui quand vous vous
regardez le matin dans votre miroir vous
vous dites quoi
j'aime bien non même avant d'ailleurs
j'aimais bien regarder dans les vitrines
ouais parce que il ya des villes et des
vitrines donnent dans paris et détroit
qu'on connaît et où j'aime pas qu'on
passe ensemble il ya des belleville oui
il ya certains plaisirs
alors que tous les matins je joue quand
même jour différent quand j'ai
l'habitude c'est chiant quand à dire
regardez tous les matins de nos vous
étiez petit boudoir semblait acquis avec
la taille à qui marilyn monroe
à vous d'y être marilyn monroe c'est bon
ça les cheveux comme ça non c'est pas
qu'ils sont de cheveux c'est que gg
quand j'étais petit j'étais tellement
jamais tellement les photos de marilyn
monroe j'aimais tellement les défilés
film que aujourd'hui si vous posez cette
question j'ai pages est un pur roman
c'est ressembler marine monde on aurait
aimé avoir des gros nichons fait aborder
la l'intervention ouais je suis pas homo
non non juste je veux des greniers sous
le terme on est tous les mecs étaient
pas aux mots du tout on a bien côté
simple christophe quand avez vous pleuré
pour la dernière fois
l'impression de tout temps pleurer mais
enfin en fait comme les com mail mais
mais mes larmes coulent ouvert à
l'intérieur ça ne se voit pas à quoi un
quel péché qui vous tente le plus
l'éclair au chocolat plus
ça c'est si c'était à refaire la vie
vous feriez quoi pas pareil je crois que
je crois que je ferais vraiment je
vivrai mon rêve le plus le plus profond
c'est c'est le voilier
donc je crois que tout que très très tôt
un j'aurais appris très tôt à altkirch
skipper et puis pour pouvoir me me
barrer sur la venue d'antoine peut-être
gpara vraiment 1000 et antoine mais
j'aurais plutôt envie une fête a pris la
tête pour lui voler son bateau voilà
quelle insulte qui vous a fait le plus
mal en toi qui viens de le dire qu'elle
est la dernière chose que vous faites ce
soir avant de vous coucher découpage
vous est découpée quoi par exemple cette
semaine à cette semaine voilà j'ai dit
j'ai découpé ça enfin cette semaine pour
deux soirs
ouais en gros je passe voilà j'ai
découpé sur pen sur pen
sean penn ouais trucs sur en gros un
martial allemand et qui des coloriages
[Rires]
ouais lynch plein plein plein plein
d'autres genres toujours ce petit
dossier comme ça me fait toujours avec
vous son de tambours
j'écris tout le temps qu'il veut relier
un truc et puisque je fais souvent aussi
bon c'est j'ai toujours besoin de
petites friandises avant de m'endormir
et donc j'aime bien les six est aussi
trop ah bon c'est marrant ce serait la
dernière personne que vous ayez envie de
tuer peut pas répondre à ta vie tu as
tort douanes pour lui voler son bateau
mais ouais mais ouais mais c'est tout
moi je veux dire ça fait deux fois qu'on
dit antoine selena laërt
est ce que vous êtes déjà pensé au
suicide que stuff ça ça a dû dans mes
rêves glace et me traverser mais mais je
pense que pour aller au bout je pense
qu'il faut être très fort en moi j'suis
très faible christophe est ce que vous
avez menti pendant cette interview
bien sûr que oui monsieur monsieur
guillaume monsieur glisseurs l'histoire
salue monsieur armand hélène hélène
aussi madame darmon la deuxième madame
d'armes en matière d'armes comment ça va
trouver que c'est un jeu qui a paru un
pote genia
je tarde pas que le papier tu dois mais
avec s'ils regardent avec ses regards
asseoit ses citoyens oui il éclate ce
christophe regarder m'a offert un livre
sur les cocktails du rite général les
dessins sont magnifiques en essayant
dirait des dessins du new yorker c'est
beau geste eu droit ce que tu viens moi
je pense que je vais prendre un verre de
vin rouge
oui oui je vais prendre un verre avec le
ballon fait remettre dedans tu te lèves
toi à part parce que j'ai travaillé en
fait j'écris c'est celle d'un nouvel
album écrit jusqu'à jusqu'à 11 heures du
matin temps 15 ans du matin j'ai eu un
petit coup de barre et voulu me placer
un petit film de spike lee
en fait j'ai chuté explique t on à faire
avec un des comédiens devaient du film
et puis on s'endormirait tous les deux
je me suis bon bah je vous raconterai
pas l'album à douce amie corti là
qui est écrit là comme à mal j'ai des
hauts des bas et des moments
voilà je suis en suspension dans
l'écriture oui mais ça fait partie de
génial christophe parce qu'il vit à
l'envers c'est à dire que moi j'avais
daniel filipacchi il est un peu comme
toi génial c'est là qu'il avait des
mondes qui marchaient à lombers déjà ce
qui surprenait sa tournée dans l'autre
sens c'est pour ça qu'on est amis voilà
il avait daniel il venu au bureau le
soir à sept heures du soir c'est que
tous les gens travailler toute la
journée puis le soir c'était au monde
rentrer chez eux les merdes
je vais pas rentrer chez moi parce que
daniel qui va arriver tout le monde
voulait plaire à daniel à la cour du roi
daniel donc tout le monde restait le
soir pendant que daniel soit téléphone
soit passe et le week-end et le mois
d'août se dire que en fait ils venaient
au bureau au moment où les gens n'y vont
pas donc ce qui faisait que les gens
étaient au bureau 12 mois sur 12 7 jours
sur 7 24 heures sur 24
oui pour le club car pour lui plaire toi
ce n'est qu'en même temps que tu vie à
l'envers comme ça tire tous dans le jour
étudier la nuit ça va depuis les puits
et puis j'ai deux présences 14
4 j'ai toujours j'ai toujours je m'étais
adultes donc j'ai toujours pour ça que
j'avais toujours un petit peu une
carrière traînante lui parce qu'en fait
il a fait des trucs extrêmement
populaire et m'aider je me suis perdu
marilyn ou succès fou des trucs très les
45 tours quoi c'est vrai il ya musée et
en même temps des trucs plus
sophistiqués un homme plus grand show m
e album à la maintenance étaient culte
la bad a préféré torturé dans libération
java qui était un album cette double
page super culte c'est marrant
d'ailleurs parce que de ces années là il
y en a pas beaucoup qui sont devenus
cultes sans cela qu'est ce t'as fait
comme ehrhart à christophe dans ta vie
ta plus grosse erreur
moi je suis en fait je pense pas je
parle pas des idées des feux rouges et
les trucs comme ça des conneries comme
ça c'est aujourd'hui les vois je n'ai
pas l'impression que l'erreur si tu veux
c'est quelque chose que tout cas nourri
mon existence et et qui fait que que je
suis ce que je suis bon ça veut pas dire
je suis un cadeau je te tomber sauf chez
deshors qui m'ont qui m'ont aidé à
avancer presque très marrante c'est
christophe qui a fait des trucs super
babelgum pop music comme stéphanie où
elle est mais si mais si c'est la police
la profonde comme evil à quoi mais c'est
parce que j'ai pas ce que c'est je
propose à christophe c'est toi c'est
mignon je fais nous rêver encore pour
toutes les générations qui sont autour
de cet homme salut à toi et avec grand
avec une sincérité et tu le sénat
[Musique]
je les dirai mont bleu
les mots qu'on dit avec les yeux eux
à l'intérieur deux
dans l'un d'eux
à
tous les mondes
d'où l'émoi
oh
je me les démons bleus tous ceux qui
rendent les gens heureux
une histoire d'amour sans parole n'a
plus besoin du protocole
c'est tous les ans disc ou futiles
[Musique]
dernier quelqu'un
le style de
non on retombe à fond
retrouvailles
et
non
il ya plus d'horloge plus de clocher
[Musique]
dans le square les arbres sont couchés
je reviens parle
trains de nuit
m
bon
je lui donnerai léman bleu
les mondes et avec les yeux
toutes les excuses que l'on bat sont
comme le baiser
que l'envol et toutes les toutes les
tél
denat et
non
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si l'ambiance pour christophe c'est un
cetain tous comment il a dix troyer la
chanson là les motos c'est la venue est
venu opératique la cfu jeunes à bien non
mais ce que j'aime c'est commencer c'est
l'imprévu chez pas savoir ce que j'ai
fait en fait ce qui me plaît dans les
concerts c'est pas quelque chose de deux
commandos gérer et formaté tous les
concerts c'est quelque chose de
commandes imprévues ou en fait ce qui me
plaît plus il dans le danger suivent pas
le danger
le plaisir steve documents d'ubs je
répondais rendu comment du de se mettre
en danger
cependant a prévenu le plaisir de
comment contenu du ratage mais alors
happé du ratage esthétique
[Musique]
on
où
demain on est de soie rose
[Musique]
j'étais en bulles
mais peut-être
bonjour faudra s'y retrouver
avec moi
et
verdi
tandis pas maudit un peu vieilli
dans ce
exki ces ondes n'ont rien dit quand je
chantais dans les
cadre de londres
un peu noyé
dans la foulée
ce rang
sophistiquée toutes les nuits
respect
peut-être
et
nature
[Musique]
trombe et eau
avec moi
[Musique]
e
olé
non dit rebondir
un peu vieilli mais mes musiciens sans
rire
sur ce calendrier qui c'est joli
j'essaie
napoli encore une fois
les accords
sera
soc 10 tickets
[Musique]
mais
même les anglais mais
un beau jour
faudra t il
retourner
avec moi
m
hélas
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jg j'ai la même sensibilité quand
j'avais 15 ans chassions que chantait la
même passion que je chantais dans l'est
dans les zoos comment à la vache enragée
qui savaient ce qu'était à golfe-juan un
bar il y avait les comment les
américains qui arrivait et guillaume
bernad et lévis quand j'avais 14 ans
ouais elle venue j'en avais pentagone
eut lieu le jour 3 way et chantages cap
jusqu'à temps qu'ils après qu'ils
retournent au bateau les mecs gens ne
chantent et en europe 1
nos champs tête à vue nous chante en
français la médecine chantant llop
chantes tu vois au toit des jantes le
blues mais feeling et uniquement leçon
tu vois et les ricains quand on tournait
sur le triptyque à la meuf de la vache
enragée du t il et il change quoi amuser
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
toi cette chanson était importante en
amérique a était important parce que
c'était l'époque de la pension way était
à montlhéry
ouais c'est gentil cirer ses chaussures
en crachant dessus
ouais ouais hein et j'adore exprimé
choses parce que je devrais je prenais
un pied le matin à cirer des chaussures
parce que je voulais qu'elle soit jamais
cirage loin j'aimais les faire briller
et ont pris ça prenait du temps sur ce
que tu veux le rendez-vous après tu vois
plus que des jeux prend du temps et
j'avais du registre sur top cracher soit
une génération parce que moi je ne
souhaitais pas si les chaussures étaient
glacées toujours de chaussures bah ouais
y'a que ça pour faire les pompes ça à
l'ancienne du circuit jour des
chaussures wicca survie sur ce sont les
hauts d'armance hallucinante
vernis hallucinant avec ap avec une
couture de mycologues sans chaussures de
la fraude qua non non pas du tout c'est
pas ça m'amène sont rares celle-là non
dans la vie j'adore ça mais mon père me
disait toujours tu le chaussures cirées
ont bluffés ou le fait ou pas cela pour
tous ont fini à la fais moi plaisir
christophe feu doux alors daniel alors
daniel de jouer à la fille et moi qui
fais moi et lui et moi aline revisité
titre est dans son rôle
la nuit de revisiter que la ligne à
ligne commente aline ce soir à lille par
audi sailing comme ce soir
la ligne aline avait que ça soit une
version de ce soir mais c'est bien c'est
qu'on a une comme du sang ce soir façon
c'est tout ce que j'aime
[Musique]
une
tous
on
[Musique]
j'ai dessiné
sur le sable
oh
son doux visage qui me
oui
[Musique]
puis il a plu
sur cette plage
dans cet hommage
elle a disparu
et j'ai créé
[Musique]
à pour qu'elle revienne
j'ai pleuré pleuré
[Musique]
j'avais trop noté
je me suis assuré
au pérou son âme
mais benneteau
s'était enfui
les chercher
en plus des coins
[Musique]
besoin d'un espoir
et j'ai crié
rires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
le raymond
m
j'avais trop de peine je n'ai gardé
ce doux visage
[Musique]
comme il n'est pas sur sable mou
mais
j'écris
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
m
non
[Musique]
e
est plié
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu